here's why regular hair conditioners
sometimes don't work on super damaged
hair conditioners are all about coating
your hair in a thin protective layer
your hair is dead once it leaves your
scalp so conditioners coat your hair to
protect what's left to make sure the
strands don't snag against each other
and break off more if you zoom into an
undamaged hair on the surface of the
cuticle which are these roof tile scales
there's a layer of oily substances
attached it's called the F layer it's
like the hair's natural conditioner but
chemical treatments like bleach break
off a whole bunch of this and leaves
behind groups that attract water if you
know a little bit of chemistry you
probably know that oil likes oil and
water likes water so on less damaged
hair with more of this oily F layer then
oily conditioning ingredients stick well
but they slide right off super damaged
hair it's like putting a magnet on
velcro charge conditioning ingredients
work much better like quaternary
ammoniums and specialized silicones or
polymers including my sentimental Faith
Amro dimethicone